salut romain qu'est ce tu bois à thaon
qu'est ce tu fais la départementale et
une clope la roman post ce briquet tu
sais ce que ça provoque chez toi bon bah
non
connaissez les 3 c mais si café clope
kaka la trilogie des matins qui chantent
[Musique]
voilà vous voyez que vous connaissez
mais est-ce que vous êtes déjà demandé
comment ça marche
depuis la nuit des temps l'homme
commence sa journée avec un bon café une
petite cibiche des familles et siècle
après siècle l'humanité a tenté de
trouver une explication à se produire
encore et encore
on a longtemps cru que le responsable
était la caféine accélérait le
péristaltisme tous ces mouvements des
intestins kaka vers la sortie
et puis un jour il est un bon jour de
1999 le british medical journal publie
une étude qui révèle que l' envie de
déféquer le matin se manifestent certes
chez les buveurs de café classic mais
aussi chez les buveurs décaféiné la
raison que si la caféine semble
effectivement avoir un effet sur le
péristaltisme le café caféiné ou pas
augmente aussi l'activité motrice du
côlon sigmoïde alors sigmoïde c'est pas
le prénom socialement et la partie la
plus basse du côlon celle qui est relié
au rectum savait juste avant la nuit
donc on comprend bien que quand ça remue
par là on est assez et tenter d'aller
exposer aux toilettes pour aller faire
un peu de place selon l'étude en
question ça se manifeste entre 4 et 30
minutes après le café alors c'est
important de savoir si on est plutôt
team 4 minutes ou team 30 minutes pour
pouvoir s'organiser mais en réalité le
phénomène est sans doute dû à plusieurs
facteurs
on sait par exemple que le café contient
de l'acide chlorogénique qui augmente la
production d'acide gastrique ce qui
pousse l'estomac a évacué plus
rapidement son contenu vers l'intestin
bon ok mais la clope là dedans et bien
si je vous disais que parmi les
nombreuses substances contenues dans une
cigarette
il y en a une la nicotine qui stimule le
transit et accélère le péristaltisme 1
si je vous le disais je vais vous le
dire en fait wow merci
et oui la nicotine booste votre transit
et c'est même assez fréquent à l'arrêt
de la cigarette d'être constipé et
ballonnés pendant quelque temps voir
pendant quelques semaines
du coup l'association avec le café c'est
laxatifs plus laxatifs égal
l'apd en slip voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui si vous aussi vous vous
posez des questions existentielles de
genre facebook twitter les commentaires
youtube on se retrouve très bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo en attendant mettez
vous bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]